みなさんこんばんはー
[拍手]
さて初めに皆さんこれ何とかしてますか
しています
気じゃないんですよカチカチだけどあのー末に時よくやるやつありますよなの拍子木
じゃないですカチカチです
でもこれ鰹節皆さん知っているように食品なんですね
でもこのままじゃ食べられませんかたくて
この鰹節という食品世界で一番硬い食べ物なんですね
知っています
あの硬さを測る機会があるんですけどここに針を刺しましてそれで行動を測るんです
けども
機よりも硬いんです
世界で一番た方へギネスブックにも認められています
じゃあこんな鰹節どうやって作られるか知っています
じゃあこれからちょっと実演をしていきます
今日は皆さんの前で鰹をさばきます
一番前の方ちょっと血が飛ぶかもしれないからちょっと気を付け下さいはい
じゃあちょっと始めますね
活動です
よかった笑いが取れたう
加藤者の名前の通り7の活動からできてまして
まあこれをさばいていくんですねで頭取ります
ちょっと残酷です
お腹を取ります彼らのカバーと言いますマグロで言えばこれは王都楼なんですね
でまぁ内臓があるので取り出していますこれはの卵です
心臓をちょっとハートかといっています
でこれをあのあ
左右3枚に分けていきます
左右のみと中干姉に分けるわけですね
さらにこのみようお背中がとお腹側に分けていきます
ね一匹の活動から4本の加藤武氏ができるわけです
簡単にサバゲちゃいましたね小さい上でさ
でこの鯖江た活動をどうするかといいますとまず最初に揺れます
熱湯の中で1時間以上にていきます
どこから今度は薪を燃やして熱等煙で乾燥させていくんですねそれを何度も何度も
繰り返します多いもんだと15回ぐらい
乾燥させてカチカチになっていくわけです
でもそこで完成じゃないんですねでそこに今度は栄光時期の仲間である鰹節カビという
ものをつけていきます
有益な微生物純粋培養した微生物なんですねでそれが表面を鰹節被ったら今度はそれを
天日で外で干しますまた
それを何度も何度も繰り返すんですねそれを4回5回やってまぁし上がるわけです
それが先ほどの活動無事令第対抗の鰹節元の生の活動から比べますとだいたい6分の1
ぐらいにちっちゃくなってぎゅっと濃縮されるわけです
ですから甘みもおいしさもぎゅっと6倍になるわけですね
あそんなような食品がかつお節です
じゃあこの鰹節江戸時代の頃はちょっと違ったんですね
a
会にありますように小刀で削っています
今もうカチカチすぎて小刀者削れなくてカンナで削るんですね
江戸時代というのはまだそういった状態でした
イブして乾燥させるだけそれがまあ江戸時代この日本橋の街には魚河岸がありまして
そこにたくさんの人が溢れていたわけです賑わっていたわけです
被占領えお金が動くところも言われていましたし
多くの鰹節もそこに流通網しています
したん
そんな日本橋その中で日本は江戸時代
職が非常に発達していきます鰹節だけではなくていろんな調味料が興行的にたくさん
使われるというえ
作られるということが普及していくわけです佐藤だったり仕様だったりあとは発酵調味
料である素醤油ミスをそういった
ものも江戸時代に工業的にたくさん来られることによってまあそれが一般庶民に普及を
していくわけです
まあそうすると何が起こるかと言いますと江戸時代やたいというものがどんどん生まれ
ていきますね数を作っ使った握り寿司
そういったものもあります醤油濃口醤油を使ったた例蒲焼ですとか a 面次いで側霧
が発展していく
あとはテンプラーそういったいろんなお料理ガイド時代庶民いっぱい
の方に英語普及してくるシェル終わっていく発展していく
そんな中で鰹節というのも江戸から明治にかけて
を進化したんですね何度も何度もか火をつける
そういう技術がま江戸時代の末期出来上がって現在のこういうかつお節に進化を oa
しました
この鰹節という食品カビ付けをしている発酵させた発酵食品なんですね熟成している
わけです約半年かかります出来上がりまでいる
ぎゅっとカツを乾燥させているのでこれ自体すごい
タンパク質の塊なんですね約7割ぐらいがタンパク質です
中にはアミノ酸必須アミノ酸という外からも摂取しなければいけない栄養素もたくさん
含んでます
だいたい10グラムをうけるったものを食べると雨の場合たり
プロ1本分くらいのは皆さんも撮れちゃいます
あとは dha epa というまあ多価不飽和脂肪酸っていう光栄あの血液サラサラ
にするとかそういう成分なんかもまあ
含まれているわけですそういう素晴らしい食品がかつお節
なんです
じゃあこの鰹節というものは日々の食事やお料理の中でじゃあ何を皆さんに提供して
いるんでしょうか
それはのお料理というもの一の味でできています奄美サンミン園ミニー苦味そして甘み
この中の甘みというものを鰹節は皆さんに食事を通じて提供しているわけです
それぞれの5つの味というものは必要なエネルギーであったりへ
毒物を見分けるそういった味が分かれて5を構成しているわけでこの中で旨みというの
はタンパク質を表しているわけです
甘みというものはお料理をおいしくするものなんですね
ですからお料理をおいしくする度剤のようなもの
ですから鰹節の使ったを出し先ほど飲んで頂きましたけれどもそういったものはまあ味
のインフラということが言えると思います
その味のインフラであるをだしを使ったお料理 a 和食
まあこの一汁三菜を基本とした
私を使った絵日本食の形これが非常にバランスが良くて健康的なわけです
そこに甘みと顔立ちというものは貢献をしているわけです
鰹節の旨みというものはイノシン酸という旨味成分から成り立っています
でもう一つ有名なものですとグルタミン酸というものがあるんですね
これは代表的なものだと国から採れる旨味成分になっています
でこのグルタミン酸とイノシン酸というものをこう合わせると
一+一眼にじゃないんですね
1+1がだいたい7ぐらいに美味しさを感じることができます
それがうま味の相乗効果というものです
これを使うことによってより料理をおいしく
さらに塩分を抑えることもできます
甘みによる満足感で塩分を抑えても美味しいお料理ができるんですね
あとは油も控えることも a できるわけです
しかもさらに良いことなんですねを出して先ほど飲んでいただいてを出し100ml
だいたい3キロカロリーしかありません非常にほとんどカロリーがないんですでも
美味しかったですよね
味がちゃんとして
でも同じ量の油を飲んだとしたらどれぐらいだと思います
だいたい900kcal あるわけですだいたい1日に女性であれば
2000キロカロリーぐらいが1日取るカロリーだと思ってください
その半分くらいがその油だけでとってしまう
それって大変なことですよね
で砂糖とか炭水化物こちらも非常にあのカロリーはってだいたい400kcal 同じ
量を100グラム取ればということでこの出汁にカロリーがないということ
これが非常に良いわけです
で日本の食事というのは先ほど見ていただいて一汁三菜の形がありましたけれども非常
に日本の食事は健康的でバランスがいいんですね
そこで三角形が映ってますけども pfc と書いてありますこれはそれぞれタンパク
質脂質炭水化物を表してまして3大栄養素と言われるものですでこのバランスが
10年代から80年代は非常に日本食一番良かったんですね
それ以前というのも脂が少なく炭水化物に偏っています
では最近どうなっているかといいますとだんだんちょっと脂が多くなってきたんですね
これ原の食の欧米化とか
油を使う食事がまあ増えてきたということを表しある
はしています
ですから和食はいいところだしや素材のうまみによる美味しさが基本になっていると
いうことです
それだからバランスが様を言い pfc のサイクルのバランスが容易
そして低カロリーであるということそれに対しテーマ世界の料理は油と
糖質による美味しさが基本となっているですからまあカロリーが高くなってしまう
傾向があるわけであそこがやはりいいところになります
この形ですね一汁三菜と言われるまあ当たり前の日本の食事の形です
ねお米を中心とへ主食として魚や肉の主催
そして季節の野菜を使ったまあ副菜類そしてを足しを使った桜庵
そして漬物である河野ものをこういったものを摂ることによっていろんな食材を
バランスよく食べることができる s color 先ほどの pc イヤーさらに
ミネラルパラン
びたみんそういったものもうまく撮れるというのが健康的な食の理由なわけです
では世界の中での食事はどうなんでしょう
世界にも出しとか甘みというものはあるんですね
フランス料理で言えばまあコンソメとかありますし分4フォーンというものもあります
中華でいいバターん
そこの写真にありますように中華だと干しエビとか
鶏肉とか干し貝柱使ってお出汁を取ります
ただしお料理自体それプラスやはり油が多いんですね
そうするとやはりカロリーが高い
またそこにありますようなファーストフードだと単品で食事が関係してしまいます
そうするといろんな食材がま取れないですからまあちょっとバランスが悪い偏る後は
揚げ物をバックも食べるとやはり油が多い子様カロリーが高くなってしまう
そういった意味では和食がと世界の料理ま違う所の一つの要素でもあります
じゃあ世界の料理先ほどのバランスどんな感じなんでしょう
みてくださいアメリカとフランスの2005年から2007年のバランスを表してい
ます
非常に脂質が多いんですね
まあこういったバランスなわけです
では
先ほど飲んでいただいただし旨味というモノは和食だけに使えるものなんでしょうか
昆布や鰹節の星
決してそんなこともないんですね
これあの洋風にアレンジしたよう料理なんですけれどもだし巻き卵を養父にスフレの
ように炊き上げたものです
ここに出汁をかけて食べると非常に美味しく養父にもアレンジができていきます
またこれはミネストローネ風に鰹節だし屋昆布だしを使ってそこにトマトを合わせた
ものです
こういったものにも応用ができます
ねこれはカルパッチョです出汁のジュレを使ってまぁ様風に仕立てており
でこちらあのパスタを茹でているんですけども
有名なシェフがこれやってるんですけども
このパスタを茹でるときに後部等で入れてるんですよ
そうするとそのパスタ自体が甘くなってしまうんですねおいしくなってしまう
そこに馬に出しというものをうまく使っているわけです
で先ほど言った
うま味の相乗効果鰹節の旨みイノシン酸と甲府のまみグルタミン酸合わせると1+1が
マナになる
ゲストこれはかつお節と昆布だけの話じゃないんですね
他にもいろんな食材はこの旨味成分を含んでいるわけです
トマトにもぐるたみさん入っています
鶏肉にはイノシン酸動物系のものは五ノ神さんの甘みになりますですからイタリアン
なんかはこのトマトとこの鶏肉出すとかそういった旨味をうまく使って味わいを作って
いるわけですね
そういうことを考えれば馬木旨味を上手く使うことによってう和食だけじゃなく
いろんな食材
国や家族子も含めてより料理を美味しく健康にしていくことができるというふうにまあ
考えています
馬には味のみではなくバランスの良い健康的な食事でまぁ世界を
映画をに変えていけるそんなような食材
度と考えています
で皆さん先ほどを出し飲んだとき笑顔になりませんでした
美味しくて
ありがとうございますで馬にはやはり世界を美味しくする映画をのもと
そんなような食品だと思っておりますぜひ皆さんもこのお出汁を通じて甘みを通じて
日々の食事から世界を書いていけるんじゃないかあそんなようなアイディア
思っておりますちなみにあの私18歳から体重変わってなくて
あの太るメカニズムよくわかんないですよ
まあそんなそれも甘みのおかげかなみたいなことを考えています是非甘みで世界を
おいしく
皆さん笑顔になって頂ければと思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]